el candidato que resulte elegido en las
elecciones presidenciales de francia se
enfrentará a un reto muy importante
reducir las emisiones en un 40% para
cumplir con el acuerdo de parís de 2015
los objetivos climáticos del país deben
seguir lo estipulado en la estrategia
nacional de bajo carbono que engloba 7
sectores entre ellos transporte
agricultura y energía la independencia
energética del país se impuso como
prioridad por la guerra en ucrania en
francia la energía nuclear es la fuente
principal de electricidad pero a futuro
el costo del mantenimiento de las
centrales y el tratamiento de los
desechos podría aumentar de los 12
candidatos o 7 están a favor de
continuar con la energía nuclear
emanuel mckeown como medida de
transición ecológica está a favor de
construir reactores cpr la candidata
conservadora valérie pécresse y la
ultraderechista marine lepén también
apuestan por los reactores de agua
presurizada 6 de modo del partido de
extrema derecha reconquista propone
construir 14 nuevos reactores y
prolongar la vida del parque nuclear
existente a 80 años en vez de los 60
años actualmente mientras el candidato
de izquierda ron luis alonso como la
socialista anne hidalgo y el ecologista
y aniquilado quieren poner fin a la
energía nuclear de manera progresiva
uno de los objetivos de los acuerdos de
parís es la neutralidad carbono en 2050
emanuel mccomb es el único en proponer
la descarbonización de la industria
pesada y al igual que ya ni grado
apuesta por las energías renovables
rolling meloso ambición a disminuir de
65 por ciento las emisiones de co2 para
2030 desarrollando masivamente el
transporte público pelean y texas quiere
incitar y no castigar financieramente a
los hogares para que tengan un consumo
más ecológico en su programa ningún
automóvil nuevo funcionaría con energías
fósiles a partir de 2035 el sector
automotriz joya industrial francesa
enfrenta desafíos en materia de
medioambiente y de su uso en medio
urbano roll y pelotón quiere disminuir
el uso del automóvil invirtiendo en
infraestructura para las bicicletas y
aniquilado prohibir a partir de 2030 la
venta de vehículos nuevos que funcionen
con combustibles fósiles por su parte la
socialista anne hidalgo quiere facilitar
el acceso a los carros eléctricos y
emanuel mack con crear un para este tipo
de vehículos para los hogares más
modestos las propuestas de los
candidatos en materia de energía y de
medio ambiente son variadas incluso a
veces similares sin embargo para los
expertos en el tema no son lo
suficientemente ambiciosas para poder
cumplir con los objetivos firmados en